I am Conan O'Brien, and I ...
(audience cheers)
Good news.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I just want to say, good news ladies,
I am groot in the streets and I am baby groot in the sheets.
(audience laughing)
Wait, that's not good.
Yeah, well I don't really get,
I mean, I guess it's your cute
Well anyway ...
in the sheets, but you know.
Yeah I know, exactly.
(audience laughs)
Hey, Comic Con is in full swing.
All the big events are happening at Hall H,
that's the place to be, Hall H.
(audience cheers)
That is the place.
In case you're wondering, the H stands for,
holy shit, that's a long line.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheering and clapping)
Ah, a celebration.
I know.
There are a lot of great panels at Comic Con,
a lot of great panels.
(audience member screams)
Uh yeah, thanks
for owing that concept.
(audience laughs)
The creators of West World held a Q&A today.
It's interesting, yeah.
(audience cheers)
Yeah it was uh, yeah, it was just them asking the audience
can someone please tell us what the hell our show is about.
(audience laughs)
Please, some big idea.
[Andy] Yeah.
Yeah (laughing).
All the big stars are at Comic Con.
In fact, the cast of Game of Thrones
will be here tomorrow night.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Here's a tip, if you're coming and they offer you wine,
whatever you do, do not drink it.
(audience laughs)
Don't drink the wine.
Speaking of Game of Thrones,
one of the big moments in the history of that series
is when Arya Stark is told a girl is no one.
(audience boos)
Yeah.
Coincidentally, that's also the new slogan
for the Republican Party, they have that all worked out.
(audience laughs)
Hey, it very nicely works.
(audience cheering and clapping)
You gotta work a little politics into this thing.
(audience laughs)
[Andy] Yeah, yeah.
It can't all be a world of make-believe.
(audience laughs)
It is so great that all of you came to Comic Con
because this place is not cheap, it is not cheap.
I heard this, and I couldn't believe it,
the average cost to attend Comic Con is $1,603.
[Audience Member] What!
That's true, that's true, yeah.
So finally a chance to spend the money
you all saved by not going to prom.
(audience cheering and clapping)
How we doing, are we still friends?
Are we still friends? We still friends?
Yeah, (laughs) I love that, everyone's like
hey, oh we're getting a free pop figure, alright.
(audience laughs)
[Andy] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience cheers)
Oh, oh, wait, or are you?
(audience laughs)
People in the crowd are like, "You better have one."
(laughing) Yeah.
"That's the only reason we came to this piece of shit."
(audience laughs)